[Music]
on this saturday night
uncovering the truth in another province
an investigation begins at the site
of a former nova scotia residential
school we spoke the truth
and now the truth is coming forth the
painstaking task ahead
a saskatchewan residential school
survivor walks to ottawa
plus a heat wave in toronto kicks off a
hot dry summer for canada
could an increase in wildfires be a
concern when it comes to covid19
and a mysterious brain illness in the
maritimes
the discovery of a potentially new and
unknown syndrome
is scary the race to find a cause
[Music]
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
our nasser good evening and thank you
for joining us
the search for the truth is underway at
the site of another
former residential school after hearing
at the discovery of 215
unmarked graves in kamloops bc a nova
scotia first nation enlisted the help of
an archaeologist
who is volunteering his time to find any
lost children who died at the
schubennackety indian residential school
jesse thomas has more on the scale scope
and significance of this search
a search using ground penetrating radar
began
saturday morning at the site of the
former schubernachety residential school
in nova scotia
anthropologist jonathan fowler is
working with a team to investigate the
site
this work needs to happen now and it
needs to be done thoroughly and it needs
to be done
rapidly without sacrificing quality it
operated from 1929
until 1967 and was the only indigenous
residential school in the maritimes
instances of abuse have been widely
shared by former residential school
survivors like alan knockwood
the education was through punishment and
they tried to make me turn me into a
white guy
a caucasian they succeeded knocked the
language out of me
demolished in 1986 it's still a place of
trauma for the migmaw
the community is hurting and mourning
following the apparent discovery of 215
children buried at the former
residential school site in kamloops bc
knockwood who says his aunt attended the
schubennockitty facility told him there
were burials here
i remember coming up here with her and
walking the grounds and saying
and having her point out they're buried
here they're buried over there
they're buried over here given the
discovery in kamloops the mi'kmaq
community wanted to act fast and search
for any new evidence of burials
and i called jonathan just and roger
just to get their thoughts
on the potential of looking at this site
and they
automatically said yes fairly quick and
uh and i said you know we run on no
budget
and they said they were only due for
free knockwood says it's important to
exhaust all search options to know the
full truth
but i'm glad that they're finally
getting the word out there and finally
listening
and you know the truth hurts the federal
government says there is funding
available to support this work but
sebago naggity first nation
isn't waiting for ottawa to act my thing
is that i hate myself gets stuck in the
red tape and you know gets put off for
forever right so
we just took it uh something we wanted
to get going for all of the maritimes
communities and just wanted it started
right away and this ground search will
take weeks to complete
organizers say it'll be more exhaustive
using better technology than a previous
effort jesse thomas global news
schubernackie nova scotia
pressure is mounting on the catholic
church to take responsibility for its
role in the residential school system
today pope francis met with both
vatican-based canadian cardinals
further details on the meeting have not
been released but it comes just
hours after prime minister justin
trudeau called on the church to do more
canada's first indigenous justice
minister jody wilson raybould says
trudeau
also needs to take more action west
block host mercedes stephenson joins us
to talk about her interview with
trudeau's former cabinet minister
mercedes faro the discovery of the
remains of
215 children buried on the site
of what was once canada's largest
residential school
has left former justice minister jody
wilson labeled
angry and frustrated she is criticizing
the lack of progress the liberal
government has made
on the reconciliation file she places
the blame
squarely at the feet of prime minister
justin trudeau
for the lack of concrete action to
transform the policies and practices
that would recognize the basic rights of
indigenous people she says
the prime minister made a commitment to
make that transformative change
and that's done through laws changing
laws policies and the operational
practices of government he hasn't done
that
this is hard work it's complex work but
he committed to doing it and it has to
start
at the very top wilson raybull says the
reason for this lack of action is simple
it doesn't drive enough votes come
election time
we need to have the political will
to tackle these issues even if they
don't necessarily
translate into a significant number of
votes for
a party and we're in election season and
i know that
the political parties are looking for
votes but this is a
human rights issue this is a moral issue
wilson raybold acknowledged the federal
government has implemented
some measures on a complex file but when
it comes to the transformative policies
that were promised
wilson raybould says little has actually
been accomplished
and is calling for the government to
step up to the plate
pharah mercedes stevenson in ottawa
thank you mercedes
and mercedes will have more on this
topic tomorrow on the west block
right here on global a saskatchewan
woman
is taking action to honor the victims
and survivors of canada's residential
school system
patricia ballentine set off today on a
walk that will take her through
three provinces and cover more than 2300
kilometers
she's walking to ottawa from the former
site of the prince albert indian student
residential school in saskatchewan
valentine is a residential school
survivor
and she hopes her journey will inspire
others to speak out
for years and years i had blocked it out
and didn't think about it
like it was nothing and then when
it really hits you it hits you hard and
you just don't realize how
traumatic it was until you think about
it
once in ottawa valentine hopes to talk
to indigenous services minister
mark miller about reforming the first
nations child family services system
an historic deal is set to change how
much tax wealthy multinational companies
pay in the countries where they operate
g7 nations including canada
reached a deal saturday to set a global
minimum corporate tax rate
as david aiken reports the g7 believe it
could add billions to their treasury
rich nations like canada have struggled
for years to raise more revenue
from large multinationals such as google
amazon and facebook
which often book profits from sales in
countries around the world
in jurisdictions where they pay little
or no tax
if we see the reality in the world there
are a lot of corporates that find ways
not to be taxed at all now in an effort
being branded as a tax
fairness initiative g7 finance ministers
including canada's christian freeland
have reached a deal that would see
multinationals face a corporate tax rate
of at least 15 percent in jurisdictions
where they make their sales
we're going to level the playing field
and inject that principle of fairness
into our global tax system that's the
price in canada
the combined federal provincial
corporate tax rate right now is about
26 percent this will affect other
jurisdictions that have a much lower or
non-existent rate
um and could potentially help canada uh
play off its other strategic uh benefits
freelance said the initiative is good
for canada
multinational companies need to pay
their fair share of taxes
jurisdiction shopping allows them to
avoid
doing that but the federal conservatives
oppose this global tax deal
although we strongly support
uh taking steps to combat tax evasion
and tax avoidance internationally
we know that happens but that policy
should be set in canada because there
are
i believe serious ramifications not only
for our sovereignty
but our ability to promote our own
economic
interests here at home in canada but the
g7 finance ministers believe a corporate
minimum tax
could raise tens of billions of dollars
for governments who have gone deep into
deficit
to prop up their economies during the
pandemic saturday's agreement lays the
groundwork for more intense talks on the
issue
next week when g7 leaders including
prime minister justin trudeau
gather in england for their first
in-person meetings
since the health crisis began david
aiken global news
ottawa a heat warning has been issued
for parts of toronto where the
temperature is forecast to soar above
30 degrees for the next several days
luckily lifeguards are back on duty at
the beaches which were officially
reopened for swimming today because
environment canada says highs between 31
and 34 degrees are expected for the next
few days
emergency cooling centers are also open
providing air conditioning
resting spaces also for the public
nighttime temperatures are expected to
drop
to only 20 degrees and with temperatures
like that
and a hot dry summer on the way for much
of canada
it's no wonder the threat of wildfires
is growing
but there is also concern the flames
could cause more than just
damage dust and smoke but spread
dangerous pathogens
in the air as jamie morocco explains
that's sparking even more concern about
the spread
of covet 19. as wildfires burn in
manitoba smoke
fills the air for hundreds of kilometers
a danger to local residents health but
for reasons you may not realize
there is the potential for people to be
breathing in things that
that might cause infections pathogens
that could make you sick
by launching a drone into a wildfire
leeda kobesier a professor of wildland
fire science at the university of idaho
found as soil plants and animal matter
burns it exposes thousands of bacteria
and fungi
surviving the heat she explains these
organisms get picked up and sent into
the air
essentially you know smoke acting as a
biological
conveyor belt um that is that is
spreading biodiversity around the world
we can see that they're there whether or
not they are
able to infect somebody is a different
question but for dr don sin it's not a
question
there's no doubt about that the
vancouver-based respirologist sounded
the alarm last year concerned about the
spread of covet 19 amid wildfire season
and while it hasn't been proven the
virus could travel in smoke
sin says the theory makes sense there
have been some smaller studies showing
that they are well carried
by particle matters and air pollution
particles
he's hoping to see it studied further a
heavy lift according to the bc center
for disease control
there's no way we'd be able to say they
got it from the smoke
unless we could you know do whole genome
sequencing on the virus and the smoke
and whole genome sequencing
on that individual and anybody else
around them the focus for kobsier and
her team
is to confirm whether the hundreds of
pathogens they found are in fact harmful
to humans
the hope to be prepared in the face of
any new illness hitching a ride
jamie rocker global news toronto
when canada started hearing about the
novel coronavirus a different disease
was stoking fears in new brunswick
in early 2020 doctors identified an
unusual combination of neurological
symptoms in a cluster of patients
for every eight people who catch the
disease one has died
as ross lord explains the province is
racing to find out what's making people
so sick
a year after new brunswick doctors
started grouping cases together
they're still stumped about a brain
illness that's killed six people
and afflicted a suspected 48 others the
discovery of a potentially new and
unknown syndrome
is scary the mystery disease is
devastating
two years ago roger ellis was feeling
fine
three weeks later his life was
short-circuited he got sick with a
worsening illness
that soon left him struggling to move
and to communicate
what do you want you what you will tell
you what you want you what you want you
want
doctors still don't know exactly what
has stricken alice
they've tested for dementia alzheimer's
parkinson's psp cjd
i mean i could go on like they have done
they even did antibody testing
historical antibody testing i mean
and i've confirmed with dr marrero this
week
that he has nothing else that they can
find
you know he has no other disease that
already has a name
compounding families anxiety is the new
brunswick health system's reluctance to
reveal
anything about the disease until a
government memo to doctors was leaked to
the media
the province has appointed a new
committee of doctors to review cases and
find a cause
they're also circulating a lengthy
questionnaire for families
to find common contributing factors to a
disease that has been reported
only in new brunswick one of the problem
is basically all these diseases
they do start pretty much the same way a
little bit of cognitive disorder
some muscle strange muscle movements he
says only over time can they confirm if
it's a new disease
or a variation of an existing one at age
63
roger ellis is actually feeling better
than he was
but no one knows for how long his family
welcomes the new efforts to find answers
but wonders if those answers will come
in time for him
ross lord global news
a look back at the global pandemic that
began 40 years ago
how covet 19 is affecting the fight
against hiv aids
it has been 40 years since the first
cases of the disease
that would become known as aids were
reported in the united states
the outbreak grew into a pandemic that
has since claimed more than 34 million
lives
while treatments have come a long way
there is still
no vaccine and now some researchers in
the u.s say
kovan 19 has derailed the fight against
hiv aids
siphoning away health care workers and
other critical resources
jennifer johnson reports in san
francisco's golden gate park
a national aids memorial tribute
40 years after the u.s centers for
disease control reported the first cases
of a mysterious illness attacking
healthy gay men
aids was a terrifying diagnosis doctors
had no effective
treatment no matter how rich or famous
you were i was going to go back to my
home in california
and lock myself in my house and wait to
die because that's what we thought of
hiv
it was a death sentence but olympic gold
medal diver greg louganis doctor
his cousin told him to keep training and
compete in the 1988 games
i think it ultimately saved my life the
stigma of being hiv positive was
crushing to members of the gay community
the disease looked different to the
world after basketball star magic
johnson revealed his diagnosis in 1991.
researchers struggled for 15 years to
find effective life-prolonging
treatments
i think people tend to forget the sorrow
the difficulty the suffering that came
before that
we have made a remarkable progress
dr perry halquitus has been living with
hiv for more than 35 years
the virus has taken his former partner
and a close friend just a few days ago
i thought that part of my life was over
i thought the death of my friends was
over
and it's not but there is new hope
moderna which
race to create a covet 19 vaccine soon
plans to start clinical trials on a
potential hiv vaccine
currently anti-retroviral therapy helps
patients live longer healthy lives
but 1.5 million people are still being
diagnosed with hiv each year
and hundreds of thousands die this is a
disease that continues to exist
and one for which there is no vaccine
and one for which there is no cure
many believe the u.s could see its first
increase in aids infections in years
after so much medical attention and
research was focused on coven 19
why advocates continue to push
governments and the medical community to
find a cure
for decades after the virus was first
discovered
jennifer johnson global news washington
still ahead the unique tool in canada
shining new light
on the damage covered long-haulers face
you're watching global national
we're starting to learn more about the
long-term impact covid19 can have
on vital organs but there are now
troubling signs
about its effects on our vascular system
on this week's edition of the new
reality canadian science is shining a
light on the damage an
infection can leave behind here's donna
friesen with a preview donna
farah as people recuperate from covid19
researchers are looking into what lies
ahead for some of them who have
lingering symptoms
they're known as the long haulers and
one of the many things they're trying to
figure out is
what the virus does to blood vessels
this week on the new reality i talked to
one scientist at the university of
saskatchewan
he and his team are using the canadian
light source it's a light brighter than
the sun
to look incredibly deeply into blood
vessels
what we do see in the severe covid cases
is the lining on the on the inside of
the blood vessels
that becomes infected causes
inflammation
and swelling around the blood vessels
and what that causes is for for the
blood vessels to to contract and clamp
down
so there's there's just less area for
that
blood to flow through in the blood
vessels if you just
reduce blood flow to the heart you can
have
life-threatening arrhythmias so
disruptions in the contraction of the
heart
you can also have reduced kidney
function if there's reduced blood flow
to the kidneys
certainly the brain lots of people
report brain
fog and other cognitive impairments and
these
these are all part and parcel of
other vascular disorders that that have
already been well studied for decades
and we're now pulling a lot of these
pieces together and seeing that they
they do fit into this puzzle with covet
infection
the tool he is using to do this is
amazing it's the only one of its kind in
canada it's called
a synchrotron and it generates a beam of
light millions of times brighter than
the sun and that allows researchers to
look right down to the molecular level
at all kinds of material
including tissue from blood vessels the
point of this is to understand what the
long-term risk factors might be
for people who got coveted and survived
but there may be things going on inside
the blood vessels that could affect
major organs and could lead to higher
risks of things like stroke
and dementia even erectile dysfunction
it's fascinating research it's happening
right now here in canada
farah all right looking forward to the
story thank you donna donna friesen
and you can watch the full story on the
new reality tonight at 7 pm right here
on global
what do you get a legendary pilot for
their birthday
next the fly past fit for a major
milestone
on the eve of d-day a canadian fighter
pilot named stocky edwards turned
23 years old while serving overseas
the boy from saskatchewan had barely
seen a plane before signing up for the
military
he went on to become an aviation legend
so it's no surprise a fly pass was in
store
as his bc hometown celebrates its new
centenarian
the 100th birthday bash also featured a
drive past parade with over 200 cars
local dignitaries military members and
rcmp officers joined the public
celebration
beforehand edward sat down to reflect on
his life
in the skies i would still would like to
be a fighter pilot
somebody's had like riding a bicycle i
did 373
combat missions and the day it was
the war was over before this thing was
over
it was a feeling of what do i do now
i've been getting up every morning early
combat they were in the air so
all they wanted to do was go and do a
job for somebody
in the u of gifts people were asked to
donate to his wetland and wildlife
conservation fund or the stocky edwards
legacy trust a fund for young canadians
pursuing careers in aviation
his birthday wish has raised over 125
thousand dollars
so far and on behalf of all of us
happy birthday stocky and that's global
national for this saturday night i'm
farah nasser thank you for spending part
of your evening with us
tonight's your candidate is marsh lake
in yukon territory
thank you for watching i'll be back here
tomorrow have a great night